Hey, hey, motherfuckers.
According to this it could be
an acute subdural hematoma.
Great. Get in there and operate,
Dr. Google.
Ugh, it's a fungus, they think.
Benign fungus.
Great title for your memoir!
Come all the way up!
-Fuck you.
-Come all the way up.
I am surround by snakes
and fucking morons!
He did not fire me,
he said it was just gonna take
a little longer.
What I think he meant to say
was that he wished that Mom
gave birth to a can opener,
because at least then
it would be useful.
I take over and we just--
you know, you two, under me,
co-presidents.
Can we think about it?
-KENDALL ROY: Of course.
-I thought about it. Fuck you.
You lack killer instinct,
you're wet, you're green,
you're intellectually
insecure--
-Okay, bullshit. No.
-SHIV ROY: ...you're not
emotionally strong enough,
-you have addiction issues!
-Okay, that-- that's enough!
I'm not saying I would make
a better CEO.
That's unsaid.
It's not unsaid
when you say it.
All in favor...
of the vote of no confidence
in Logan Roy.
Me. My hand is raised.
Oh, no shit, Judas.
You better be smelling
your fucking armpit, Romulus.
It's my fucking company.
You are a fucking nobody.
But, Jesus Christ,
-fucking amateur hour
at the fucking circus.
-(SHUSHING)
People come to us because
we don't sell them on anything.
No packet of fucking
bleeding heart, United Nations,
Volvo, gender bender horse shit.
Why can't he come to us?
Well, I guess
he's the president.
Ugh, fucking Californian,
shrunken little raisin.
He's selling me things I want
at a fair price?
So what's next? Fellatio?
ROMAN ROY: Hey, Pa.
How's the hooker
with the heart of gold?
Nice vest, Wambsgans.
-It's so puffy.
-Thank you, Roman.
What's it stuffed with,
your hopes and dreams?
-I just think it's for the best.
-GERRI KELLMAN:
Tom, you need to shut up.
This is the time to get
your conscience out and shout,
"Hey, look at me,
I cannot tell a lie.
I'm a good little boy.
Look at my ding-dong."
Maybe you'll meet
a wealthy widow
and you can seduce her
with your sad eyes.
She can keep you as a pet
up in Westchester.
I'm thankful that I am going
to be marrying
into one of the most
kind and loving families
in the world.
ROMAN: Are you not gonna be
marrying Shiv anymore?
(ALL LAUGHING)
This whole family
is a nest of vipers.
They'll wrap themselves
around you,
and they'll suffocate you.
Cousin Greg is moving
to Staten Island?
-No, no. I don't know.
-My God! Did you hear this?
I'm just looking at a place
out there.
Greg is getting
the ferry to work.
Check out Bryan Ferry.
Dude, why stop at the ferry.
Just come in from Cleveland
on the Greyhound.
We talking to each other
on the poop deck
of a majestic schooner?
Is the salty brine stinging
my weather-bitten face?
No? They why the fuck
are you wearing
a pair of deck shoes now?
-I'm in Canada.
-TOM WAMBSGANS: Excuse me?
Canada?
Canada with the health care
and the ennui? Why's that,
cock sock? (CHUCKLES)
Um...
I'm-- I'm driving my grandpa
down for Thanksgiving.
Oh, Greg, fuck your grandpa.
Yeah, okay. You're on--
you're on speaker phone, Tom.
LOGAN ROY:
I hear you bent for him.
Wha-- I what?
I hear you bent for him
and he fucked you.
KENDALL ROY: I don't know what
you're fucking laughing about.
I'm not even laughing. What?
Romulus, when you laugh
please do it at the same volume
as everyone else.
We didn't get you from
a hyena farm.
Thanks, Pop.
Right, um...
He's like a... sweaty corpse.
TOM: He looks waxy,
like an unshaven candle.
Mm, I'm Kendall,
and I'm a sassy little bitch.
He looks demented.
Why's he so shiny?
You're a fucking prick.
He's like a sex robot
for Dad to fuck.
He's like an old beaten dog.
Well, he's both of those things,
and also a piece of shit.
ROMAN:
Check out fuckin' Papa Smurf.
How's selling the family cow
for magic beans?
Oh, yeah, yeah, that's right.
Yeah, just a dipshit,
a sex pest,
and a Grand Old Duke of Dork
on a Central Asian vacation.
No, nothing to see here.
ROMAN: Where's the actual
head doctor guy?
I wouldn't know.
No one tells me anything.
Well, I hope he can cure
your serious case
of being a bitch.
-Ow, fuck!
-(CHUCKLES)
-Fuck you.
Good news is that the Pierces
are entertaining our offer.
But, bad news, they're enquiring
about your moral character.
(SNIFFS)
That's okay. Nobody here
has any glaring
substance abuse issues
that almost brought down
the company, right?
You're onto gossip, investments,
art, movies, tittle-tattle,
wider cultural interests.
But what if your wider
cultural interest is hatred
and Instagram?
-Just asking for a friend.
-Ooh, me! I think she's talking
about me.
Just, uh-- just know your role
and execute.
Well, my worry is that Kendall
may come across as too cool
and likeable.
This was supposed to be
choreographed.
That's about as choreographed
as a dog getting fucked
on roller skates.
If you wanna arrest me,
go ahead.
No, really, just go ahead
and try.
Quick question. Do you think
he even knows what a jail is?
He literally only knows
it from Monopoly.
I'm still applying for the job
of President
of the United States.
And do you think that that's,
like, a natural progression
from "never done nothing, never"
to "most important job
in the world?"
-Well--
-Like, could you maybe get
a little experience
at, like, a CVS
or something first?
Yeah, or just like nickel
hand jobs under a bridge.
Cut the horse shit,
know your role.
Hail, my fellow toiler men.
I have returned
from real America,
baring the gift of sight.
Roman, you're a moron.
You're treating me
like I'm a piece of shit.
-You are a piece of shit.
-ROMAN: Fuck you!
Do the management
training program.
-(GROANS)
-Ground floor.
Work at a slaughterhouse.
Learn the price
of a gallon of milk.
What the fuck
is this obsession with milk?
You know who drinks milk?
Kittens and perverts.
-(INDISTINCT CHATTER)
-So, uh, how is it going?
ROMAN:
Gobbledy-go fuck yourself.
Oh, amazing.
Marry, fuck, kill...
the executive floor.
-The executive floor.
-ROMAN: Mm-hmm.
-Ugh, I'd kill Ray.
-Of course.
Fuck Elsa.
-Hmm.
-Marry Gerri.
-Gerri?
-JAMIE LAIRD: Yeah.
-Marry Gerri?
-It's a small pool.
You'd marry Gerri?
You sick fuck. Gerri!?
-JAMIE: (CHUCKLING) Yeah.
-You like Gerri?
You know, if I were capable
of any sudden movement,
I would totally pounce on you
right now.
Should we... get married?
What?
You know, not that,
like, uh, an equivalent thing.
Like I abduct you and force you
to live with me.
Tha-- That's not equivalent.
-No.
-GERRI: I guess you are family,
-and he does treat family
differently.
-Yeah.
No, sure. Although,
he did once call me
-the cunt of Monte Cristo.
-(ALL LAUGH)
Have a drink, have a drink,
you beautiful Ichabod Crane.
Fuck you.
Greg, this is not fucking
Charles Dickens World, okay?
You don't go round talking about
principles. Man the fuck up!
Secret, Greg?
Look, the-- the actual envelope
says 'receipts'.
Ooh, but they're not in fact
receipts.
(GASPS) Greg.
You're a criminal mastermind.
What polyglot genius could ever
hope to crack your
impenetrable code?
-Shut up.
-God.
-Easy.
-Sorry.
-Here's a strategy, Tom.
-Um...
Why don't you pipe down
till you come and tell me
I've got a grandson coming?
Hmm? Or are you
shooting blanks?
Bore on the floor, over there.
Gerri, stand up! Stand up!
GERRI: Actually, I...
To be perfectly honest,
I've-- I've had a few doubts.
You see. Everybody, do you see?
Honesty.
Yeah, I c-- I think-- (STAMMERS)
I've had some doubts too.
Oh! Fucking doubter.
Over there.
On the count of three,
the last piggy to eat a sausage
is the mole.
That doesn't seem like
a very good system.
I can't reveal my sources.
Ugh, but it's Greg.
Yep, buckle up folks.
We're gonna get an invite
to the Great National Latrine.
See who wants to take
a public dump.
Now Mr. Fuck
is going to Washington.
LOGAN: (SCREAMS) No!
I'm not dignifying that
fucking question
with an answer.
You can both fuck off.
If you look at the Ledger Pack
at 15B, by a Gregory Hirsch.
Is that someone known to you,
Mr. Wambsgans?
Uh, no. No, sorry.
-No?
-No? No, Tom?
Hmm?
Oh, yes, yes. Sorry, yes.
Know-- Know-- Known to me?
Yes. In that sense, yes.
Do you know what is special
about the hours
between 3:00 a.m. and 5:00 a.m.
on the night of March 12th?
Uh, no, sir.
That was the only
two-hour period
in which you did not send
an email to Mr. Hirsch
with the title,
“You can't make a Tom-let
without breaking some Gregs.”
MR. EAVIS: You sent the same
email to him 67 times
in one evening.
I guess it was a joke.
(CHUCKLES)
I think the obvious choice is,
and I hate to say it,
because he's such a swell guy,
is...
(MAKES WHOOSHING SOUND) ...Tom.
How about Tom with some
fucking Greg sprinkles.
What-- What precisely are
"Greg sprinkles?"
Like a Tom sundae with a--
with a little Greg cherry
on top. (POPPING)
What the fuck?
He ate my fucking chicken.
-Mm-hmm.
-So, what next? Stick his cock
into my potato salad?
All right, all rise
for Pope Big Dick.
LOGAN: Like, uh, Romans
amongst you Greeks,
I'm sure you find this all
rather...
you know, big, vulgar
and boisterous.
You hit me; I will fuck you up.
-Fuck you, man.
-Ow!
(GASPS)
(INDISTINCT ARGUING)
-ROMAN: Stop it.
-Shit head.
-GREG HIRSCH: Wh-- wh--
What am I doing? Ow!
-TOM: (GRUNTS)
No!
Stop, Tom, we're friends!
-You're one of my best friends.
-TOM: Fuck you!
Meeting over. Fuck off.
-Fuck off.
Fuck off.
Oh, fuck off. Fuck off!
-Just fuck off.
-Fuck off, thanks.
Fuck off.
-Fuck off.
-How 'bout you fuck off.
-You, fuck off.
If you can't do it, fuck off.
-Good, right? Is it whisky time?
-Shut the fuck up.
And I'm proud of my family
who have helped me get here.
What are you waiting for?
A kiss?
Fuck off.
Be gone. Bye-bye.